our next guest is no stranger to the
screen Dominique Fishback has acted in
several hit TV shows and films including
the deuce Judas and the black Messiah
project power and show me a hero now she
stars in the newest Transformers film
called Transformers rise of the beasts
she plays Elena an archaeologist's
intern in this clip she and Noah played
by actor Anthony Ramos meet the
Transformer Beasts for the first time
check it out
who are you
why are you hunting for the king
um rash don't worry you boys got this
[Music]
hey over here kitty kitty
Dominic Fishback joins us now how are
you doing well good morning welcome we
appreciate you so growing up you said
that you never believed that you would
star in the Transformers movie yeah why
is this role so important to you well I
feel like I've always wanted to be an
actress and I would watch Steven say I
want to do something like that so so I
transforming the set but I never
imagined that they would have me that I
would be the girl chosen they didn't
have a lot of lead actresses that looked
like me they came from where I came from
so it didn't really seem as as close
attainable to you yeah I mean a lot of
things did seem obtainable but I guess
specifically Transformers it was like
it'll be something like that yeah and
for it to be that so you didn't really
want to audition uh originally no I was
like unless the chance was really big
because I give a lot no matter if it's
an audition or I get the role I'm gonna
give myself to it and I spoke to Stephen
Caple he said no I want the characters
to be from Brooklyn tell me all about
Elena so if it's from Brooklyn
in the house
Nate said it's the best Transformer
movie he's seen and he's seen them all
oh that's awesome I'm so glad thank you
and I I you know once you got the role
you really grabbed it I I was I was
hearing an interview with you when you
were talking about how you gave pages
and pages of notes on your character and
what you think should happen how it
should go down narratively talk to me
about that I do that a lot for all of my
characters I usually Journal as a
characters and I told Stephen too I said
you know if you if you like the work
I've done just know I come from theater
so talking about character and
development and the Arc of the story is
really important and it doesn't change
no matter what the genre is or the
medium is and I said so if you if you
want me just know he was like you can
give me your notes at two o'clock in the
morning I said okay so I did and then I
got to see what the writers about two uh
two or three times just to talk and it
wasn't about that my ideas had to be in
it it was just the opportunity to talk
about it and feel heard I love this
Dominic you go from I don't know if I
should audition because I don't think I
could get it to here are my notes
take that Mr director can I talk to you
about swarming it's right now on Amazon
it's a multi-part series you are a
knockout in this role because she plays
cray cray cray with a capital cray cray
cray tell me about this role for you
what I like about is we get to see all
of the different we saw many different
layers and levels to your talent well
this one too
um they told me that Donald had a role
Donald Glover Donald Glover had a had a
role for me and uh when I got into the
meeting they told me all about the
character About Dre and then said they
wanted me to play Marissa which is the
character that Chloe Bailey ends up
playing yeah and so I love being like
man I got to play Dre so I told my team
to say you might have to fight for it
and I said I mean we've been fine our
whole lives so this is no different and
um but I got on the phone with Donald
and he said well tell me why I said well
I have to do something like Judas and
black Messiah and Transformers what do
you do next I want to stay on my toes I
don't even want to know what I'm going
to do next when I was when I was younger
and wanted to act it was not based off a
genre and I wanted to do anything that
felt good to me and could show
versatility well you certainly do that I
mean because she's she plays someone
who's obsessed with a I'll say Beyonce
type character who is a mega star and
then it's off to the races with that but
I'm fascinated by you because at 10.
remember when you look like a Disney
princess today thank you and you said
yeah 10 you wanted to be a Disney star
what did you want growing up
um I just watched it I watched it and
said I got it I gotta do that I want I
want to be like Lucy so you like comedy
and which is why I was excited about
swarm because I got to bring a lot of
physical comedy the way she looks Around
The Way She Moves yeah all of that is
like really physical so it was fun to
tap into that so when you were in
college you played a one-woman show
where you take on 22 different
characters so it's one woman but it's a
lot of characters and now that show is
going to become a one-woman play right
produced by uh Jamie Foxx so yeah so
converted yes it's a one woman show that
I wrote as my thesis to graduate from
school
um and then Jamie Foxx on and said he
wanted it uh wanted it to be everywhere
so now he's EP in it has a special I
think that's so but I think you were
amazing and I like that you and I have
something in common we were talking
backstage guys because we're both single
and available yes oh and you said we're
not looking for the same age group I'm
happy to say I don't want anybody
actually sure
Dominique you say you're a big Manifesto
big Manifesto so what are you doing in
this particular area of your life oh in
terms of getting my husband yes so yes
in terms of getting your husband yes I'm
reading a book called calling anyone
calling in the woods which makes you you
have to identify the ways in which
you've contributed to the success or the
failures of your past relationship so
it's not about just blaming somebody
else's identifying your triggers and how
you show up to things and gives you uh
things to do I'm like and the author
that book is
thank you
Transformers rise of the Beast premieres
in theaters June 9th